hello we literally just finished
watching the new trailer for Avengers
infinity war we're about to give you a
reaction we also are gonna go over
different details we learned we're crazy
excited people's heads are nodding like
harder than they've ever not heard
before
and we're all just getting so psyched
for this premiere which is moved up to a
April 27 welcome by the way - who knew
rockstars news it's our deep dive into
all the big stories of the week you
should be able to watch this and not
have to check any websites or anything
cuz we got it all covered so easy yeah
we're gonna talk about last Jedi the
blu-ray release a lot of new stuff came
out with that a ton of Game of Thrones
news also dropped this week Deadpool
stuff and The Walking Dead is gonna be
referenced real quick we got more stuff
coming but real quick
I am Phillip Molina joining me at the
table are I'm Sam basher and Becca's
filling in nice to see you here because
we just met
yeah I really I love the chandeliers and
the red carpets you want a crystal in
here wow it's a throne room for Erik
speaking of Erik
he is only not here because he's
currently working on the Avengers
infinity war trailer came out today he's
not gonna have a breakdown right there
in the corner he's crying he's weeping
this is not different for any other day
where he works here he's scribbling all
over the TV he's gonna help with sharp
we straight to it but he's gonna find
this little details you miss we're gonna
do a little bit but mostly watch that
video that's coming out this weekend to
find out every single little new thing
and it was a ton of new footage by the
way oh yeah in that so we watched it now
we're gonna give you our first reactions
let's start with any new things that we
noticed in this trailer if that was Erik
he just sneezed he's trying to sabotage
this cuz he's not you must have to get
more views like get it alright he's
working really hard it makes sense
I knew that you notice lots of stuff I
had Gomorrah I feel like is the most
important she's ever been in any movie
so far like because she's like that she
knows what's happening like she knows
the deal with Thanos so that's pretty
cool to have her intro also she
referenced my favorite thing that
vandals has ever done in comics is snap
because he actually yeah he does that he
snaps and then half of the life in the
universe's it just
he literally it evaporates into nothing
he just there's a scene where Hawkeye is
just he's just screaming as he
disappears into nothingness it's a great
scene - spoilers one hand does one side
of the universe in one hand as the other
because you could accidentally mess it
up I'm gonna do a look great no but I I
was so worried about them not treating
the gauntlet at that level because we've
always talked about it like couldn't
technically if he has the gauntlet he
can like jump into DC movies it's not
like he could do literally anything
there's a lot to break apart without
like right off the bat I was like oh
they're going their own serious with
this they're going hard with like how
much of a threat Oh Peter quill talking
I'm not allowed to touch the table Peter
quill talking is one of my favorite
things I love the guardians franchise so
him and Iron Man it ah oh my god that's
also a first to us for us to see - we
see in that moment we have Peter quill
Iron Man Drax and spider-man like
alright they weren't lying yeah yeah
induction they're not lying they're
actually all there and they're all there
thank you know in an Avengers movie they
would put the heroes together what but
also dr. strecher do - well he was
yelling out a little Yelp near the end
of that there was a creepy greasy grey
alien man just going Jewish shoes and
put more needles in you shoes shoes
you're gonna find anything and
baby he looks like a little deal of
acupuncture maybe is that what he's
doing to get as I check this out Lauren
this age group yeah why is this door
locked group I did like the post car one
of the like ninety post-credit scenes
for guardians to he had like a little of
like branches on his face so it looked
like he had the emo haircut they don't
have that in this trailer that's a
bummer but it's still cool people know
one wears over the face meme kids would
internet kids we don't know no one else
would the first Incredibles oh yeah my
favorite thing in this trailer is to me
it's kind of a callback to the most
jealous I've ever been of a man it's and
they I love that they put this in there
for me it's when remembering Captain
Captain America in Civil War when he
holds the helicopter and he does it the
bill goes foo and he flips it so you
could totally see his whole bicep just
gets bigger and bigger and like holding
that together and I always remember
thinking like holy crap how strong is
Kat and holy crap like how many steroids
in disguise before because I'm aroused
as a man another man that was me well so
then how do you feel about that that
moment that I'm referencing here where
he's holding at danos his fist and the
perfect there you go you're kind of come
down
[Music]
what if what if he just keeps going
what if he just keeps going it's kind of
it's like that's how you beat like the
flash for anything another movie it's
just like him not working at his full
capacity so it's like there's like yeah
oh yeah and just like when he's holding
Thor's head like what if you swim like a
little great a single take all the way
through Hawkeye is not there he may
Danis male and in this movie right at
the farm just like Hawkeye I do really
like though in that moment even though
we're kind of like okay but Captain
America can't actually be that strong
right that danos has that look on his
face for a second where he's thinking
the same thing to me it's kind of like
this guy can do this and it reminds me
of it was actually in a DC cartoon but
where Batman dodge is one of Darkseid's
Omega beams mhm and Darkseid goes like
it can't be done that's never happened
and writers but I still it always made
me like it totally works on me where I'm
like Batman is that cool yeah cap is
having that moment for me were like yes
cap is stronger than all of the gems
yeah but like Thor and Hulk barely make
it like fighting each other and Thor
looks totally laid out by Thanos like
100% if he's able to get to the point of
grabbing by the head unless like Daniels
like snuck up on him and god I'm like
caps not gonna last long also he could
just do this you know like he's like
capsule and I'm pretty tight he could
just go like this and kind of like throw
a line yeah maybe got a space don't just
teleport him wear your space now yeah
and you're gonna teleport half of them
have a limb they don't have the universe
half a cap balance
spaces if he's just surprised at how
powerful cap is or if he's just like did
I remember to turn off the stove he just
looks just how am I also cable this
reality son lets me be cable I also wait
there was a thing I did want to bring up
Oh seeing the black order for the first
time was actually really cool so we've
got a whole video coming up actually
about who slashed what they are alright
and I Erik is making more noises get
someone assault yeah one other moments
sure uh well when when iron man is like
oh what's his name again
I don't know cheeseball she's no she's
oh the whole movies gonna be like she's
like the Doctor Strange line I mean the
whole point of it is to be because
you're like I just want Garcia galaxy to
give everybody a big hug on earth like
that's what you want
like in our brains were just like that's
exactly what was like that like yeah
exactly I want them to reference your
towers on one oh you guys are the
guardians of the galaxy is it our galaxy
cool where were you when this story
showed up and just sort of like pillows
and we put metal man up against him when
you guys are the guardians of the galaxy
I want all of those moments have one
they just call out every little thing
also they look at spider-man they're
like you messed up our timeline you want
a six hour movie yeah this is my problem
with ensemble movies in general I got a
real beef with them because there's not
enough time to really dig into those
characters you just get the two big
fight scenes and gonna be two big
battles in this which is I think maybe
like the midpoint battle and in the end
battle which is still better than
Fantastic Four where there was just the
end battle and the midpoint was just a
video montage it's like there is that
one fight that was clearly on the worst
green-screen they ever had like it's
like the thing comes to get mr.
fantastic so bad it's like he had that
we should do a whole breakdown fan for
stick
so real quick before we move on now that
you've seen this trailer is there
anything that you're like okay even
though I'm nervous about whatever or
hesitant on something just what are you
so damn giddy about saying mmm the
Doctor Strange
star-lord team-up where he's jumping on
like the little platforms and like it's
the fun with the camera angles and like
the zero dree G kind of adds like a fun
element to all the fighting especially
spider-man you shouldn't be able to work
really well in zero-g kids he's it's all
based on from any web yeah it's in also
I dig his suit it's metal like that's
yeah it is but like I didn't realize it
was like how like how like tactile it
look when you could like I feel like I
could touch it like that's that's kind
of cool that you'd feel like a suit of
armor actually so he seems more
formidable in this he had yeah he's
still probably get a little lean squish
I'm just I'm a huge fan of the guardians
franchise and I'm excited to see them
finally mix in that fray I've just any
interaction with all those characters
I'm gonna be really excited about
especially rocket and Groot
mm-hm yeah I think the guardians
franchise pulled the entire Marvel
Universe like way beyond the boundary
they had set for a comedy and like how
fun it could be before when you even
further exactly so now I think like
anything that they're involved in is
going to kind of get tugged that way
which is fun
that's gold for me that's my jam and
just Peter kind of seem like a jerk more
more so of a jerk than like normal like
that line even though it's really funny
it's like it's kind of a mean thing to
say yeah but is he super dumb like what
it's a super didn't realize it totally
because he is capable and like but when
he said that I'm like I kind of forget
that you got taken away from Earth when
you were like 12 or something like that
still though something question mark
real quickly can we get some blank
trivia card questions or trivia question
cards so we can pull them out we're
doing I'm doing a mr. fantastic right
now it's pretty cool but in the meantime
we're gonna move on to our trivia
question and then don't worry Becca you
don't
it was beforehand don't you know the
answer it's okay Sam and I no no it's a
fun question blank sheet of paper yeah
none of us have seen the question but
the winner at the end just gets it gets
kind of complicated at the end in the
show always falls apart because of it
music cuz we make this for you and it's
a marker and that's for you and you guys
can play along at home just don't cheat
in the comments I always love when
people leave comments clearly after
we've revealed the answer so this week's
trivia question is in spider-man
homecoming what corny science joke do
the two atoms on Peter Parker's shirt
say to each other in spider-man
homecoming what corny science joke do
the two atoms on Peter Parker's shirt
say to each other all right so those are
our answers so don't look at them just
don't look at me don't look here on
answer you can't know what it is and
then in there okay cool so we'll go over
the answer to the trivia question at the
end of the show and there's special
prizes that are weird and they make the
show weird and that'll happen at the end
but moving on next we're gonna talk
about the news flash update actually
real quick I don't know if you guys
heard about this you probably did
because if we talked about it was there
were test screenings for Deadpool -
woohoo and I've been seeing it go both
ways but in general it kind of seems
like maybe they're not being received -
well there are do it they are doing
reshoots they're gonna include way more
cable in the movie and also way more
Domino in the movie yeah we don't we
fingers crossed basically a lot of
people are worried about the director
not returning because there's a falling
out with Ryan Reynolds no the new
directors oh they're trying to bring him
is that like tying in they had bad
different ideas on how to do the sequel
and now it's kind of a question of like
Oh was he actually essential and part of
it knows you want to get hired you got
to be easy to work with yeah
the second man I've been the most
jealous of ever in the haunted movie
with a house movie with a medieval [ __ ]
there you go
oh man you can rock it's always muscles
that's nice job you got a great beard in
that you like jealousy like in my nether
regions yeah okay that's okay sure
moving on to our other big news this
week the blu-ray came out for Star Wars
the last Jedi know along with it we got
a bunch of bonus footage deleted scenes
commentary from the director Eric and I
had a mandate and watched the whole
thing commentary and all the deleted
scene stuff um but there were some
really interesting details so I'm kind
of gonna let you know some stuff so you
guys don't have to go out and then you
guys kind of wait as I go but I'll just
fill you in so ryan johnson dropped a
lot of really interesting stuff in the
commentary first the opening shot of the
movie and every Star Wars movie opens on
shot of space after the scroll there's a
ship will cross it pans down to a planet
and it has a version of that in the
existing movie and it goes to a battle
if the original opening shot of the
movie was actually a pan down to a dome
and we're like oh is that a weird glass
world and occasionally the by hotel it's
actually the top of film fins back to
suit remember he's like being like here
anywhere it's just that and it's kind of
like trying to like haha I got to you it
wasn't a planet it was fin and then it
just cuts away to a whole different
story
Oh weird I mean I thought it was I had
forgotten about fin entirely until we
saw I saw him in that tank yeah that
makes sense that they're setting up
remember fin who's in here yeah oh they
did that kind of faked out with the
trailer with the rocks and you're like
oh we're looking at space and they kind
of focused up and you're like no you're
looking at the branch were raised being
training I'm like that's actually kind
of cool and till they cut away and
you're like that was pointless that was
just to mess with you also in force
awakens I remember that the trailer had
Ray like junk diving or whatever and
there's a moment we listed you see a
bunch of stars and you realize no it's
like a door with a bunch of holes in it
and you
reveals Merlin the Stormtrooper eyes
alright so they do mess with us
sometimes that one just seemed kind of
like a weird one too like hey here's
Finn
just kidding it's not gonna be about
Fame also most of the movie doesn't
really need Finn that much like a weird
way to start his movie moving on Johnson
also said that Luke's line it's time for
the Jedi to end was actually a really
long complicated line in the original
one and then when they sense the trailer
house another trailer entire thing they
were like yeah we're just only gonna use
this part where he says I'm the Jedi
then and he was like yeah that's way
better yeah like cut everything else out
good that's it wit also for the the
force chat scenes Eric calls him forced
time between ray and kylo the first time
chat yeah I had the two actors actually
in the same locations with each other so
they could shoot the scene actually
across in an empty room and there's the
camera in front of it tennis balls the
girl but that's cool cuz that moment
actually really does work for me
it's so rare that you get to see a
villain and a hero really interact you
know have a lot of sexual tension it's
usually like a favorite scene in movies
where you can put them in the same room
but not while they're fighting so one of
my favorite examples that is in the
movie heat I was thinking this thing
yeah Pacino and Robert De Niro I never
seen the movie I know it's the two of
them and they sit down at a diner and
they have this like huge tense moment
but it's in a conversation with each
other I mean watch heat if you haven't
seen he got one Kill Bill when the
daughters in the room and they're in the
kitchen
I forget that is so only the first one
and yeah when the bride and Vivica Fox
is characters they've brought the house
school whatever
I mean if you had the choice watch it
happen or just like find her dead body
later what would you pick the second one
I think Brian Johnson had a really great
choice he made there where this is in
the commentary he uses the language of
film editing so he puts one person on
one side of the frame one person either
so the frame crosses their eye line so
that we feel a scene happening between
these two people except they're you know
a galaxy apart from each other there
were other moments where you tried to
make that happen
where I ended up getting cut but where
Luke actually is kind of having like a
moment a very depressed moments when
he's just found out the Han Solo died
and then it that's when it cuts to
Carrie Fisher and Leia kind of just
staring out the window for a little bit
not necessarily saying that they're
doing the exact same thing between
exactly they had versions of it but in
that moment in the final cut it's a
little bit more unclear what she's
thinking about
she's clearly mourning but in the
original cut it was a little more clear
also Johnson himself by the way was in
the movie a couple of times turns out he
well he had affected on at least he
smashes kylos helmet so you know kylo it
really goes to town on his helmet
apparently all of that smashing it only
broke into two pieces so then he had to
go in and he had to like just stomp on
it and beat the hell out of it and
instead of selling it on eBay
and then his hand is also the clue in
the close-up where Luke takes Hans Gould
and dice from the Falcon cockpit the
close-up hand is actually Ryan Johnson's
Han weird full Mark Hamill I don't know
why like this he's like no we need full
full graphs guy your hand acting is bad
very dainty with his the lightsaber
fights were all edited later with full
hand grabs
ryan johnson also said that he wrote the
dice into the script after reading The
Force awakens script which had a scene
showing Han hanging the dice back up in
the cockpit that scene was cut so
Johnson wanted to have you know still
acknowledge like he did put him
and they are therefore did see as a
casual fan I didn't know there were dice
in there so when he found when he took
them off casual fan he took them off I'm
like oh I mean that ship hasn't been
used for a long time anyone could have
put that in there like it didn't mean as
much like what if he took the whole
chess board and he brought it and he was
like look sorry they assign it's not
what it's called
Rian Johnson went into detail about
Benicio Del Toro's character DJ who you
know comparing him to a classic Star
Wars scoundrels like Han Solo except he
didn't want this scoundrel to ever like
complete that art can see the light and
become the good guy at the end so his
original final words in the movie where
they say they like he's turned on Finn
and they're like oh you're wrong or
something he in the movie I think he
says maybe right like that something
like that yeah in the script yesterday
wrote wrong and rich like he's just
wrong and a rich guy now it's like yeah
that actually is what that guy's thing
is like who cares yeah but it's like
maybe because it's like Erica right now
sorry yeah we all want that though
people like being rich and that's that's
a truth to that place del Toro improvise
that line by the way to say maybe all
right Johnson sorry did they say
anything in the commentary about the
accents because it was so out there
ridiculous and I loved it well Benicio
is yeah or speech offense got a choice
that he brought and ryan johnson does
talk about it but he kind of pulls one
of those like and then you know Benny
Benicio he's so brilliant the choices he
makes with the particular dialect and I
was like the stutter he just makes him
stutter before he says everything and he
has like a tick to matches up with it
he's like knocking on the table I'm like
in calm down no but I liked it yeah he's
really good I like the choice but I'm
like dial it back you can't dial it back
a little bit
it's hard to be consistent you know
consistent consistently through every
word right Johnson also admitted to
sneaking in a really nerdy reference to
the Zork a text-based computer game in
the players would receive a Zork
midpoint those Zork mid coin in the gold
coins that DJ steals from the ship the
nerdiest reference I think has been a
probably also finally Johnson libraries
on the general importance for him to
convey the force as more than just a
superpower which is kind of previously
it's been like people who said no you
know it's everything but it kind of in
practice just looks like a superpower
yeah their x-men yeah yeah sorry yeah so
so he wanted to show here on Explorer
Ray's journey from adolescence to
adulthood I and combine that kind of how
the force is more complicated so that's
what he's trying to show in that mirror
cave scene where he can see you can see
all the versions what is explained that
behind her yeah he's trying to show
essentially character arc in a movie the
hero's journey kind of thing the arc
that she's supposed to go on he just
wanted to call out that in that moment
that like critical moment when you're
going from being an adolescent to
finally you know who you're going to be
that there's actually like a million
different ways you could go and she's
there they all like are you know right
there and you don't know they all look
the same but it's actually a different
version of you you're going through this
right now I'm in seventeen yeah I
thought it was beautiful I really liked
that moment because you know we're
always in this quest to figure out who
you are and that's the moment rate did
it she's like oh I'm that badass cool
got it I don't need to know what my
parents were it doesn't matter fans
aren't gonna care are they
I was flashback scene I was definitely
confused deeply by that scene because I
thought the question was I just didn't
know what was happening I'm like is she
in her own mind right now or is this an
actual like mirror dimension that she's
standing in right now like what's that
what's what's happening feelings about
the same scene Brian Johnson recorded
that commentary before the movie came
out so he actually doesn't really
acknowledge any of the backlash or the
divisive nosov of the way it was
received good yeah it's cool because
it's a much more raw authentic thing the
thing I'll say this is just me speaking
murder for myself it does come across I
think he would have chosen some words
differently it comes across like he kind
of was like getting off on it but pretty
into the idea of like tricking you and
like oh you think this is gonna happen
I'm gonna do this instead and that that
was like almost his modus operandi for
the entire movie for scripting and like
like the same thing of the Finn pan down
where he's like see you think you're
gonna start with movie but it's not
gonna be as far as maybe I'm gonna prove
that as many times as I can and he comes
off a little bit that way in the
commentary and that's kind of one of my
beats of the movie mmm actually that's
why I like the movie so much is that it
actually like it breaks the mold and I
guess right it becomes more approachable
to me instead of me but I haven't it's
like when comics become like not
approachable it's just like oh there's
like 80 years of stuff the same with
Star Wars it's like others connected
like movies I have to watch that ReWalk
movie to understand what this reference
means or play this one game from the 80s
is like I feel like I can't get in on
the fun and this I kind of broke that
down for me the exact same way cuz I'm a
casual Star Wars fan as well and this
was when my favorites which makes the
die-hard Star Wars fans so angry telling
that they just you see like the blood
Darth Maul's their favorite character I
think you guys are totally right it can
be that experience for some people and
for some people it's not but in that
sense looks like jump to like 10 or 15
years from now we can all see the way
the prequels kind of really quickly like
faded that that interest in them because
at the time people are like they're so
good and then like like two weeks of
distance kind of made people oh there
you go yeah
this movie do you guys think especially
coming from your perspectives of you
know it was maybe one of your favorites
what do you think the legacy of this
chapter of the Star Wars story is gonna
be I think it'll last more I mean force
awakens was basically a reboot of a new
hope and for me I liked it because I
liked the style of comedy that Rian
Johnson brought and I mean I think
that's why I like guardians and Thor
more is because for me any action film
is better when it doesn't take itself
too seriously he definitely says that
but more so and in more mainstream but
like way that's funnier to me and then
that's what can resonates with you so
that opening moment which I think for a
lot of people is a good decider where
yeah post is playing a joke on Hudson
saying like people what's very important
situations okay good but anyway I where
some people are like oh that's not Star
Wars and it sounds like you're kind of
like yeah so do you like it or do you
not like it objectively as the scene all
by itself yeah it's gotta evolve it's
gotta change with the times and I'm on
board with that but JJ is coming back so
we're gonna probably just fix a couple
things fix a couple things from last gen
I will go back to how Force awakens was
sad what you want y'all I didn't like
force awakens either don't pretend like
you did I don't think it's the same
people maybe it is it is three people
online they're very angry at me more
than my friend D here and some guy in
New Zealand there you go great alright
another quick update real quick the big
news this week from AMC is that The
Walking Dead and the spin-off beer The
Walking Dead are finally gonna have
their crossover episode
it's an event they're calling survival
Sunday because no one cares about the
days of things air anymore on April 15th
they're actually trying to turn it into
an event they're gonna go to movie
theaters actually and show that season 8
finale of The Walking Dead followed
immediately by the crossover episode of
fear The Walking Dead it's gonna be at
season 4 premiere and the character
Morgan is actually gonna be the one
linking the two series and Morgan is
just everyone's favorite
I'm sure this is gonna go over real well
and it's gonna bring those ratings back
up simply silly fine across all right it
feels like pandering it feels like it
can't give the audience exactly what
they want cuz they don't really want it
they're gonna complain about it but
maybe that doesn't matter so long as
they watch it was a baby
see it's just like Benicia baby moving
on to something that I feel more
strongly about which I was more excited
to get to this sorry is that there's so
much Game of Thrones news this week ton
of stuff came out about the final season
and also about the Game of Thrones
prequel series 1 got in the works
because it's the truth the last one what
it's a final one last one before it's
dead it ends the world is over Game of
Thrones done but George RR Martin's
gonna come up with the next book like
any minute
Stephen Hawking actually wrote this so
anyway we are very desperate for HBO to
throw us anything related to Game of
Thrones so we thought we'd share with
you a couple of updates we're putting
together out one first an HBO Insider
think that someone in the building on
HBO
during the table reads was there and
said that one by one as the actors saw
their characters started to fall down to
their deaths
I'm getting chills yeah and by the end
it's the last few words of the final
script that everyone is just bawling
tears are falling down and then there
was an applause that lasted 15 minutes
sorry yes it's exciting like your hands
it hurt yeah 15 minutes just like two
minutes of thinking of retro very insane
[Music]
speaking of drawbar one actually and
Glenn described the finale scripts just
brilliant
but that he also added and this is what
I'm saying it's not gonna please
everyone I think it's more than that the
doctors are gonna show up and there's
gonna time it's not time for Andrea
music I know I think it's gonna be the
fact that some people are gonna be like
that's the end
you know like either it's not gonna
resolve some storyline the daughter
would mean everything to just be
finished did you guys watch The Lost yes
and I'm fine with the finale of loss not
the whole time just last season just in
real specific it's a really weird the
show I'm curious what you just give me a
head real quick what you guys are you
gonna listen in the comments what you
think it would take for you to be like
damn yeah that is a satisfying ending
and what you're okay with them not
answering I'll throw out
a recent example I think Breaking Bad
did a great job of that was a satisfying
ending so it's just a nice example there
also when it comes to things to look
forward to the game of Thrones prequel
series that's in development HBO
executives have said that there are five
different scripts in contention for the
same new spin-off project I thought they
were making all five so what other ways
at the same time five different shows
all prequels that's what I had heard
yeah none of the actors know which one
they're on yeah but they are just saying
they're gonna go really big with it the
idea is it's gonna get a huge budget
probably similar to the game of Thrones
Season 3 budget but just for the
beginning of these prequels so that
budget by the way was fifty million
dollars five million per episode that
broke all the records at that time this
final season by the way of Game of
Thrones is 15 million dollars per
episode and we can't cure cancer but
anywho hey Sean Bean spoke in an
interview this week about what Ned
Stark's final words were saying that
when he was murmuring murmuring prayer
mummifying that prayer that he says to
himself and we should note that in the
Spanish subtitles for the episode in the
international versions of closed
captioning and labeled Nets finals words
as they're better listeners in
spanish-speaking cultures yeah well and
Sam you know that phrase in Spanish
right mm-hmm
there it is you know we did not add they
also set the most people on fire did you
see that oh thank you HBO yeah thank you
so that's that's a nice that's that's
maybe the most Ned thing that he could
have said by the way is just protected
like that guy was just like penultimate
family man yeah with just a wacky family
I could see him sorry I'm like in a
Christmas movie anyway just I
I was about to make a marriage one and
they remembered the red wedding happened
it's like maybe there's a funny way to
do it we talked about the final season
of Game of Thrones before but from you
guys which characters would you be the
saddest to see die which one would just
be like no they can't do that he almost
died to see which is already ruined
because we're down one dragon but I
thought that three heads of the Dragon
were gonna be eaten arias John and
Tyrion and they were gonna ride around
on those dragons and burn all the White
Walkers and we were just gonna be good
you know oh I think one of if one of
them died maybe would that be the most
devastating the most devastating for me
is Denarius because I too am a mother of
dragons so if you're watching this I
know you are I'll hang out - sorry Sam's
part of the deal really is watching
I was making some faces during like the
applause and the crying cept I know it's
emotional I'm not judging that but I've
seen all these I've seen every episode
of this and so I'm up to date but I'm
gonna call him out he watched all the
episodes like once while we had the flu
yeah and it was recent no I gave myself
a week per season oh it was rough but I
ate very long it's a good show so it's
just a lot of TV to watch but for me it
would mean the most I probably if Danny
died even though I could see that
happening like story wise I feel like
that there's something somewhere that
connects to that like that that would
make sense
John raises the kid and or something
like that or we lose John and then Danny
raises all the kids I don't know man I'm
not feeling great about the incest they
don't raise their own children no one
brought up the inside yeah how do you
not how is that not the main
conversation it's like doing the sex
scene the narration that says this is
your hands when I give the 15 year old
is like yeah isn't that crazy they don't
new rock stars deep cut real fast we did
a prank back in the day when we had to
do pranks and we did a game of Thrones
prank and it was a really nice apartment
in LA was for rent you had to move in as
a roommate and you had to live with this
really attractive guy and girl and they
were dating and they were brother and
sister I and it's real stomach twisting
to watch it you can watch it it's still
on our channel it's a deep dive so you
have to go way back there that's all
about incest I can't believe what
happens to show when Eric's not here Oh
John John exactly Tyrion to me is more
about the story of Game of Thrones have
like you don't know who's gonna make it
to the end that's kind of the point like
plans to try to be king kind of never go
well but someone to start I don't say in
such a low status but definitely hated
by his own family and society like
that's the character I feel like needs
to make it just to kind of show like
there's you can't there's no one to bet
on in this kind of world yeah but that
would probably hurt the most so long as
various doesn't die just kidding we were
told you have so it's time to move on to
our new rock stars news lightning round
questions I'm gonna fire them at my
co-host who have to answer them as
quickly and without hesitation as
possible are you guys ready yes all
right here we go
once the first great yes so Sam yes
ready all right if you could design the
ideal crossover between the MCU and the
DC EU a movie crossover what would it be
and why from at Carroll BC diva oh and
she's one of our patreon supporters by
the way hi Carol I mean you gotta get
the fights between all the people you
want you get you're like you just
basically take the amalgam access event
they did back in the 90s where it was
just like they're finally putting the DC
at everybody together so you get
Superman versus the whole key blah blah
blah
but they created a plot device that was
just like there's a character that
exists in both worlds and he protects
them
Thor between them and it broke open and
that's why they're everyone's spilling
together and like juggernaut shows up in
Superman has to stop juggernaut that's
really cool right because he's
unstoppable yeah I feel like I'm doing
it because it led to the amalgam and
that's like fanboy dreams where the DC
and Marvel characters came together and
made like new characters if you guys
don't know that'd be a fun video do
where Batman and Wolverine were put
together and it made dark claw and the
Joker and Sabretooth came together and
made a hyena it's really cool so I mean
so I'll say that's like then your answer
that's why I want about them yeah yeah
it's so in it some of its dumb some of
its great it'd be awesome though that's
cool
all right Beck are you ready did you go
alright man and Hawkeye are missing from
the new infinity war trailer where are
they from at the main pokeyman pokeyman
here's what's happening so it's like a
lazy Sunday and ant-man calls up Hawkeye
and he's like hey dude what are you
doing you wanna like I don't know you
Pizza Pizza dog you want to like I know
hop around some rooftops pizzas in his
time jumping from roof to roof just
chilling you know shooting and then they
decided to go for shwarma and and
accidentally ant
shrink by themselves and put themselves
into the shwarma and then george RR
martin comes and eats the shawarma do
you even remember the question nice
pizza I was thinking a pizza right but
meeting Marvel Comics Hawkeye is a good
one to read that's alright
it can be sad sometimes - okay and
Philip if you could have any MCU
characters in a buddy cop movie who
would you choose and why from a tally
malika's lightning lightning I've kind
of actually thought about this almost
for different reasons but so my favorite
buddy Canarian yeah just making it my
favorite parent would be
vision and Rocket Raccoon and their
intergalactic like homicide detectives
and vision is just like very by-the-book
and rocket racoon is like the one that
like beats the hell out of people I love
it I want to make it hi a marvel I'm
sorry I said people Disney didn't need
to buy your Star Wars DVD different
people listening now wait if you let him
he'll stop saying that
yeah don't buy the DVD or blu-ray unless
I get to make my my movie that I already
forgot what I want to do that's how this
show works
go ahead so you've gotta have the dark
and the light
I want Gamora mm-hmm from guardians and
Korg I don't think I'd understand any of
it but I do have that thing where I can
never heard anything I feel you in
really quick fighter man yeah it's
interesting
it's proven people with accents sound
smarter to us them Americans because we
don't really know whether it's that add
us dumb Americans anyway okay and
everybody for sending us your questions
Hawkeye and Winter Soldier that's it
okay Hawkeye more fun okay I want we're
not sending these anywhere so I just
wanted so we have a more Q&A type stuff
planned actually for the future where
you guys are gonna get involved in what
we're we got going on here so make sure
to follow us on Twitter for more ways to
chat with us and actually get featured
in some upcoming videos but that's it
for that next up we take a look at
what's up next in the pipeline or videos
in the pipeline so somebody make Super
Mario
that's a truck thank you these are
videos coming out this week we've got
the obviously the infinity war trailer
in-depth breakdown Easter egg hunt to
celebrate Easter knock that out we also
have a Walking Dead episode 12 breakdown
coming from Eric - Sam what you got
coming I'm doing another MCU rewatch and
I just watched guardians of the galaxy
and it's great it holds up maybe you are
casual I think Peter I mean it's like
confidence is going through the roof
yeah I'll go do that one also I did a
slack-jawed quill what you all bleed
goodness it's uncanny
thank you and we also have an infinity
war a black order explained video coming
on so you saw them in this trailer
there's a whole story there we'll get
into into and then also we're gonna go
see ready player one tonight so
hopefully we'll have a review for you
real soon
I'm really excited for that I really
enjoyed the book even though it's not
the best writing and I have very high
hopes I tell them all right now it comes
a time for our 15-second shout-out where
each of us has 15 seconds to shout out
plug or ramble about anything you want
so Sam why don't you start us off 19
seconds on the clock go I've started
doing I've started doing YouTube videos
again I've been doing quick movie
reviews I got to I just did tombraider
and we also did a annihilation wrinkle
in time and black panther so that's the
movies that come out recently so go
check that out only stupid answers
YouTube channel it's Ben Affleck yeah
like a new rock star second is 1.8
American
say duh Becca what you got oh well you
can find me on the internet at the Becca
Scott like you probably think it would
be spelled if you can't spell it you
don't deserve to go there also I make
how-to videos about both board games and
just general life skills that I don't
know how to do but maybe we'll find it
in the video together probably we won't
hey
and my 15 seconds let's see this week
I'll give it to my friend Adams movie
it's called paperback it's available on
Amazon Prime Eric's making a face cuz he
was cut out of that movie no it's a
great movie Adam is a great friend a
terrible employee he used to work here
and we fired him but he's still our best
yeah well you said he never watches to
the end of these videos Adam
anyway that's us finally we get to
return to our trivia question we asked
and for this Becca so the winner gets to
do our final news headlines and the
loser has to improvise but you look at
me joke punchline to two just like
button each one of those stories so a
quick reminder the question was in
spider-man homecoming what corny science
joke do the two atoms on Peter Parker's
shirt say to each other
and the correct answer will do after but
here we go
Sam why don't you go ahead and start
you'll say this is Becca's answer again
I'll send up the corny science joke the
two atoms on Peter Parker's shirt say to
each other those new pants yeah my old
ones split atoms that's pretty good
that's actually pretty good
the word split is real big and so it's
funnier
I got the job there's atoms that look
like cotton candy I don't know what
added wrong nuclei you look at extra
points with the art snowbank he's dude
awesome flip this looks like a got some
on the brain all right jealousy is what
I call it okay damn what did my write
him say to each other and he says I'm
positive something something pretty
close it says I'm positive on this shirt
all right I know that oh that's a
potentially the correct answer and then
what did the two atoms say to each other
this seems right I feel like you wrote
the trivia question okay I did not what
did the two atoms say to each other
sigh you should read it it's not yes I'm
sorry I got dumped by my like oh no I
got dumped by my electron and now I'm
HIV positive
you think the teenagers wearing HIV is
right it's a real tragic the correct
answer of course is has nothing to do
with HIV weird I lost an electron
are you positive weird I did not
remember that well we don't get to judge
the judges get to judge okay so I lost I
broke up an electron and I'm HIV
positive are you pointing for me my old
pants split or I'm positive something
something that's pretty good and what if
she's better than that all right so I
win nerd Sam wins we're pointing it I
win okay and then you guys are allowed
to talk no one's not have to talk baby
the real problem they look the same like
us you can't treat people differently
just because they have HIV you're
allowed to touch them it's the mucous
membranes of the body the transmitted
disease I used to go to high school
yeah at the beginning of this speech I
had to tell a monologue as if I were
hiv-positive Oh Eric the beats you
wanted us to hit on this episode the
script it's crazy the pants splitting
positive something something it's other
than pants splitting right the word I
have a word that's on the shirt punched
Becca lost
oh speaking of punchlines you're about
to have Santi so I'll go ahead and set
you up for your job provide your joke
response but these are actually real
headlines just to wrap up the week for
you guys I so I got the joke
I got it got it got the choke just now
cuz science you ready always all right
the stranger things producers and
director James Wan are teaming up for a
coming-of-age slasher movie at Netflix
one do you wanna see that story black
panther has crossed 1 billion dollars at
the global box office and a sequel to
the movie has now definitely been
confirmed by Marvel Studios what kind of
me crazy are you crazy is a hosting a 31
our G MCU a marathon starting two days
before the release of Avengers infinity
war oh they're all gonna be asleep zing
ooh
[Laughter]
Construction has begun on George Lucas's
1.5 billion dollar Museum of narrative
art which will display his personal
collection of film artifacts and be
shaped like a giant floating spaceship
and they will be framing this one oh
narrative art dick joke here is also
going to be framed house like the Howard
the Duck is if it's going to be and
finally Nicholas Cage the real actor who
was attached to play Superman in the 90s
is actually finally going to get to play
the Man of Steel except he's gonna be
just voicing the character in the
upcoming Teen Titans go Teen Titans go
to the movies well you know they say in
Wakanda the national treasure t-shirt
thank you guys so much for watching this
week's episode of knock Stars news it
won't be aired I want to thank our host
Sam basher you can find him at Sam
basher it's his name but with a @ symbol
in front of it I'm Polina find me at
fimo it's not my name but it's a
condensed a little portmanteau of it and
my sexuality emo tiny mechanized robot
vacuum cleaner
I love robot vacuums that - Becka Scott
you can find her at the Becka Scott
thank you so much for joining us Becka
it was my great great pleasure to
Wakonda here it works every time
okay guys so comment down below about
the stuff we talked about especially
answer those questions we had about how
you won't be let down by the egg games
those family or even by infinity we're
actually tweet us at new rock stars if
you wanted to talk about stuff
especially we're gonna feature some
that's the sweets more like this video
shared around and subscribe to this
channel for all the stuff we said we had
in the pipeline it's great deep dives
and just stuff you love we'll see you
next week bye bye
II
[Music]